we begin this morning with the Robert
Muller investigation after nearly two
years of captivating the nation the
special counsels closely watched inquiry
into Russian interference during the
2016 election is over late Friday
afternoon a security officer delivered
the completed report to Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein who is
overseeing the investigation within
minutes Rosenstein passed the report to
Attorney General William Barr shortly
before 5:00 p.m. Eastern Time Friday in
a letter to top lawmakers Barr notified
Congress that the special counsel
submitted quote a confidential report
explaining the prosecution or
declination decisions he has reached we
are covering the developments from
Capitol Hill and from the president's
Florida retreat we begin now with Paula
Reid at the White House Paula good
morning good morning Michele the Muller
report is in but we still don't know
what it says and neither does the White
House which confirms it has not been
briefed on the report's findings the
president has of course repeatedly to
smear it disparage and dismissed this
investigation but right now the White
House is completely deferring to the
Attorney General about how much of this
report we actually get to see a Justice
Department official confirms Special
Counsel Robert Muller will not indict
anyone else in this investigation but
the Attorney General William Barr is
expected to reveal new information from
the report in the coming days in a
letter to Congress Barr wrote I am
reviewing the report and may be in a
position to advise you of the special
counsels principal conclusions as soon
as this weekend the release of Muller's
report has been anticipated for weeks
before departing for Florida the
president as he has many times in the
past criticized the investigation there
was no collusion there was no
obstruction everybody knows it it's all
a big hoax since I call it the witch
hunt it's all a big hug
see what happened Muller's probe has led
to the indictments of 34 individuals and
three companies while the president has
tried to distance himself from the
investigation five of his close
associates have been charged his former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
former campaign chairman Paul Manafort
former deputy campaign chairman richard
gates and former personal attorney
michael cohen each of those men have
pleaded guilty and agreed to cooperate
in the probe the president's longtime
friend and advisor Roger stone still has
charges pending which will now be
handled by federal prosecutors it's up
to attorney general Barr to determine
how much information is made public
he said he intends to consult with
Rosenstein to determine what other
information from the report can be
released to Congress and the public
earlier this week the president said
Barr should release the entire report
let it come out let people see it during
his confirmation hearing in January Barr
could not commit to full transparency my
goal will be to provide as much
transparency as I can consistent with
the law the Justice Department has a
policy that a sitting president cannot
be indicted so if there is any evidence
of criminal wrongdoing by the president
it'll be up to the Attorney General
whether or not to pass that along to
Congress for possible impeachment
proceedings Adriana
everyone's reading the tea leaves of the
letter Paula thank you